Let's take the look at the
implementation, of an optional method,
we've got in the content provider.
Anyone out there who has
done work with SQLite,
knows that putting a bunch of
inserts into a single transaction is
much faster than inserting
them individually.
BulkInsert allows us to do that.
The default implementation,
just calls insert a bunch of times.
But, we can wrap it in a transaction,
if we implement it ourselves.
Note that we've only added support for
weather forecast transactions here,
since they are the only
ones we insert in bulk.
We start by calling db.beginTransaction.
For each of the content values
passed in, we insert and
update the number of records inserted.
When we're done,
we set the transaction to be successful.
And then rely on the finally
statement endTransaction.
Note, that if we do not set
the transaction to be successful,
the records will not be committed
when we call endTransaction.